hey 42 here kevin mitnick
is an american computer hacker who
served five
years in prison some of that time was
spent in solitary confinement
mitnick was not violent so why you ask
was a humble computer geek
forced into solitary confinement because
law enforcement told the judge that
kevin mitnick
could start a nuclear war by whistling
into a pay phone it was thought
that he could use a prison pay phone to
hack into the modem
at norad and launch nuclear
missiles 900 years ago
genghis khan and his army formed the
largest
empire in history by shooting arrows
from the back of horses
500 years ago the house of lancaster
beat
the house of york in the war of the
roses
using swords armor and wooden siege
weapons
150 years ago the north won the american
civil war
using cannons rifles revolvers and
sabres
100 years ago the allies won
world war one using rifles machine guns
flame throwers mortar strikes tanks
aircraft
and chemical weapons and of course
70 years ago germany and japan
were defeated in world war ii by a
variety of opposing nations
and in the end nuclear weapons
but something was different this time
world war ii wasn't won primarily
through brute force
and superior physical weaponry like each
and every war before it
it was in part one through intelligence
and computers whilst mathematician
alan turing was working at the top
secret bletchley park
he broke the enigma code and allowed the
british to
instantaneously decode all secret german
communications
touring created a very early mechanical
computer
he called the bomb which allowed him
and his team of code breakers to crack
the enigma machine
once cracked the code breakers knew the
location of
every german u-boat attack before
it actually happened it is often said
that alain touring's genius innovation
played a pivotal role
in winning the war winston churchill
himself
said that touring made the single
biggest contribution
to the allied victory but this marked
the start
of future warfare the face
of global conflict had been altered for
good luck gone on the days of men on
horseback with bows
swords and rifles for the wars of the
future
will be fought online this means of
course that the genghis khan of the
future
could be a 14 year old boy in his
mother's basement
building his empire through computer
code that doesn't sound quite as epic as
thousands of mongols riding through the
mountains i have to say
today combat-based warfare is far too
great a political risk
so more and more world governments are
turning to cyber warfare instead
cyber warfare has one incredible
advantage over
troops on the ground and drone strikes
and that
is anonymity using internet smoke and
mirrors such as vpns
tour and encryption governments and
non-state entities such as anonymous can
launch
huge online attacks on enemy nations
without
ever revealing their identity and if the
enemy doesn't know
who exactly is attacking them then they
can't exactly retaliate
can they so the pros of cyber warfare
vastly outweigh the cons but
can hacking really cause as much damage
as guns drone strikes and even
nuclear weapons yes
yes it can and the results could be
far more devastating
full-scale cyber warfare isn't a
dystopian vision of the future
it's happening right now and one could
even say that we have already been
playing at cyber war for the past 10
years
in 2010 a computer virus almost started
world war
iii stoxxnet is a computer
worm meaning it can self-replicate and
transmit itself to
other host devices in perpetuity
but this isn't any ordinary malware
designed to steal your online banking
details
created by some teenage kid in a
basement or a crazy russian hacker
stuxnet is far more complex
far more impressive and so unimaginably
more dangerous than any piece of malware
before it stuxnet is the world's
first digital weapon designed for
international warfare experts have
called it
the greatest malware ever created
within just a few days security
companies analysts and researchers
all over the world were becoming
concerned about a new threat that was
infecting
millions of computers worldwide it was
first identified in belarus
but in a matter of days it had infected
computers in
almost every country in the world
but one country in particular iran
the vast majority of computers infected
by stuxnet
happened to be in iran this can't be an
accident this was by design
this meant it had a target
a normal computer worm has one method of
transmitting itself to another machine
two at most maybe through email or
file sharing but stuxnet
had seven this is unprecedented
stuxnet could spread via usb without any
user interaction
the second the usb would be plugged into
the computer it is infected
it could be spread over email file
sharing
or it could simply spread itself
wirelessly
over the local user network without any
interaction
whatsoever a typical malware created by
a criminal gang
which is designed to steal sensitive
data or keep your personal files ransom
in exchange for bitcoin
usually contains something called a zero
day
a zero day is simply an exploit a
weakness in an operating system
or a piece of software that allows a
virus to insert itself into a machine
and control it completely undetected
it's called a zero day because the
author of the software doesn't
yet know of the security hull within
their own software
but the hacker does so when the hacker
uses the exploit
the software developer has spent zero
days
attempting to fix the security flaw
zero day is a hacker's dream weapon
a security hole that they know about but
nobody else does
not even the software's creator now zero
day
exploits for major operating systems
such as windows
are so rare that they only
appear around 10 times each year
so if you have a zero day
you can sell it on the black market for
hundreds of thousands of pounds
it is usually worth it for the criminal
hacking groups to purchase
one zero day exploit from the dark web
because before that zero day gets found
out about and fixed
the gang can use it to infect millions
of machines and make a nice
profit on their investments through
techniques such as ransomware
and fishing but due to the rarity and
great expense
it is completely unheard of for a single
virus to contain
more than one zero day stuxnet
contained four different zero days
probably over a million pounds worth
but why four simple
redundancy if one zero day fails or gets
patched there are three more to fall
back on
so not one single software update can
stop this virus from spreading
the amount of money and time invested
into stuxnet
means it could only have been created by
a nation
state and a powerful one of that
probably several nation states in fact
after examining the incredibly complex
stuxnet code for over a month
security researchers across the world
soon realized that stuxnet
had a very specific target it was
spreading to millions of devices
worldwide and doing
absolutely nothing like a patient
assassin
stuxnet was waiting until it had spread
to
and infected one specific
location before it would deliver its
deadly payload
we now know that that target location
was natan's uranium enrichment plant
in iran the plant contained roughly
6 000 centrifuges that were enriching
uranium so that it could be used to
develop
nuclear weapons the goal of stuxnet was
to invest
the siemens plc units at natanz
these are little black boxes with
onboard computer chips that control the
spin speed of the centrifuges
and monitor them to ensure that they are
all spinning at the intended
safe rpm at all times
about 6 300 rotations per minute
whoever developed the logic behind
stuxnet had to know exactly how these
plc units and centrifuges work
this is literally as hard as rocket
science
not something your usual hacker would
know anything about
when stuxnet had cleverly determined
that it was on the correct hardware
it did nothing
it would just lay dormant on the plc for
13 days
staying completely silent just waiting
but it was doing one crucial thing
during these 13 days it was recording
all the data
from the centrifuges saving every log
that
every single centrifuge outputted for 13
days straight
then after patiently waiting for two
weeks
stuxnet sprung into action it increased
the spin speed of
all the centrifuges by several times way
beyond
their safe operating range it did this
for just 15 minutes and then
it slowed down the centrifuges to just
2 rpm for another 15 minutes
this massive variance in the spin speed
of what is a
finely tuned machine caused the
centrifuge to develop
cracks warp bend and eventually break
apart or even blow up but the most
genius part of all this is that while
stuxnet was increasing and decreasing
the rpm of the centrifuges
way beyond their safety limits it pulled
off a trick from an
old spy film you know when the spy is
sneaking into the enemy's secret lair
and they replace the feed to the cctv
camera
with pre-recorded footage so that it
looks like nothing is actually happening
well stuxnet did exactly that
remember how stuxnet did nothing for 13
days upon arrival
except record data well
whilst it was doing damage to the
centrifuges it played back
that recorded data to the plc so that
all the maintenance engineers in the
control room who were monitoring the
status of the centrifuges
would think that everything was working
as normal
the machines would be reporting a
completely normal spin speed
nothing to see here this then isn't just
a virus
this is a piece of expertly
choreographed espionage
stuxxnet even contained code that would
disable the big red off switch
that the engineers would usually press
if say
a foreign nation had inserted a rogue
virus into your plc units to blow up all
your centrifuges
yeah while stuxnet was doing its thing
it completely disabled the emergency off
switch
stuxnet would repeat this same 30 minute
routine
just once every 27
days as not to arouse too much suspicion
from the engineers over the following
months stuxnet successfully destroyed
well over 1 000 uranium enriching
centrifuges
at the iranian natanz plant
significantly
slowing down iran's nuclear weapons
programme
to this day nobody has claimed
responsibility for the attack
but it's pretty darn obvious that
stuxnet was created
by the us government anonymous nsa
sources have confirmed this adding that
stuxnet
which was actually code-named olympic
games by the nsa
was a multi-million dollar joint effort
between the nsa gchq in the uk
and israel's elite government hacking
agency
unit 8200 but iran didn't take stuxnet
lightly
they retaliated hard iran immediately
recruited thousands of hackers from all
over the country to
their new cyber warfare unit and then
they struck back iran wiped out every
piece of software from every computer at
the world's largest
oil company saudi aramco
they then hit america's banks taking
down the online banking capabilities of
america's largest banks
bank of america pnc and wells fargo
although iran didn't claim direct
responsibility this
was obviously a slap in the face to
america to say
you can't attack us in cyberspace and
get away with it
and so what happened back in 2010
was the world's first cyber war
between two countries but the scariest
part of all this is that
by targeting critical infrastructure
enemy nations can affect
physical devices disrupting our lives
and even
causing mass harm to people through no
more
than lines of computer code hackers
could
literally derail trains make planes fall
from the sky and
blow up gas pipelines and dams
if that's not science fiction then i
don't know what
is we are living in a new age of war
but according to nsa insiders stuxnet
was just the beginning
a small time operation you see the nsa
have been working on a huge
multi-national
multi-agency and multi-billion dollar
top secret operation codenamed
nitro zeus nitro zeus was a backup plan
in case iran refused to agree to the
iran nuclear deal
that prohibited them from producing
nuclear weapons
the obama administration wanted the
second option
a way to stop their nuclear capabilities
for good
if the peaceful negotiations went sour
that backup plan was nitro zeus
and quite frankly it's the most
terrifying cyber weapon
ever created we know very little about
nitro zeus but from what we can gather
from anonymous
nsa employee testimonies it is basically
stuxnet on steroids
many times more complex and intelligent
nitro zoos had the capability to infect
almost
every computer inside iran both civilian
and military and control them at the
attackers will
it could attack iran's command and
control systems so in the event of a war
iran's military could not communicate
with one another
it could hack into and disable iran's
air defense systems
so that u.s and israeli planes could
attack iran
with complete impunity iran would be
unable to shoot them down
but that's not all nitro zeus could also
shut down
iran's entire power grid leaving the
whole country
with no electricity it could even
destroy
all domestic communications and
transportation systems
and take down iran's financial systems
and banks
all in a few minutes at the click
of a mouse by some nsa employee
7 000 miles away
in the event of a war with around nitro
zeus ensured
that they would be completely
defenseless
right from the start according to some
sources nitro zeus
is still inside iran today and
can be activated at any moment
laying dormant waiting
just in case
you may not think that cyber warfare
could affect you
personally but the scary reality is that
cyber weapons whether created by a
criminal gang
terrorist group or even a nation-state
could easily be far more damaging to you
than traditional warfare critical
infrastructure
is everywhere we don't see it but it
powers our daily lives
from the filtered water we drink to the
electricity that powers our homes and
devices
but that's just a tip of the iceberg
communications
manufacturing water filtration
waste gas energy emergency services
agriculture logistics finance
healthcare transportation and defense
all rely on critical infrastructure to
function
and do their jobs for society and
that means that every single one of
these systems can be hacked
and to be honest the vast majority of
this infrastructure has pathetic levels
of cyber security
because they were likely designed and
built before the internet existed
using anonymous computer code this
spiderweb of hardware and
software that runs every country can be
disabled
corrupted overridden and destroyed
the results could be utterly devastating
when you destroy water filtration
systems
when you shut down a national power grid
they don't just
turn themselves back on it would take
weeks
even months and billions of pounds to
return
everything back to normal in that time
millions of people
would likely die due to hunger the cold
and the lack of clean water modern wars
have been mostly fought in the middle
east
and so most of the effects of these wars
have not actually been felt by citizens
of western countries
cyber warfare changes that completely
and in fact it reverses it which
countries do you think have the most
critical infrastructure wealthy
developed countries places like the us
uk canada japan and western europe
have the greatest amount of critical
infrastructure per person
than anywhere else in the world and that
means that they are far more susceptible
to hacking
and cyber weapons ironically one of the
most
well-defended countries against cyber
weapons is north korea
because the entire country is not
connected
to the public internet it is surrounded
by what hackers call
an air gap i.e it isn't connected by
physical wires
air gaps are the hardest obstacle that a
hacker can face when spreading a virus
every year the us government publishes a
document called the worldwide threat
assessment
which analyzes and predicts what the
greatest threat
is to our nations in the 2007 report
there was no mention whatsoever
of cyber warfare in 2011
cyber warfare did make an appearance but
it was right at the bottom suggesting it
was an incredibly insignificant threat
it was even below west african drug
trafficking
but from 2013 onwards
the report listed cyber warfare as the
top
threat facing our world today
but it's not all doom and gloom we can
all take some solace in this fact which
reminds us
that behind all these cyber weapons and
anonymous hackers
are at the end of the day just humans
in 2012 the fbi caught the world's most
wanted hacker because he was hacked
himself due to the fact that he used his
cat's name as his password
followed by one two three the password
was chewie one two three thanks for
watching
if you enjoyed this video then please
click here to support me on patreon
which
really helps out the channel and you can
get some pretty cool rewards
click here to watch another video and if
you haven't already
don't forget to subscribe